joining us on the mercedes-benz fans
phone line after being there in person
last night part of the tnf crew on nfl
network future
first ballot hall of famer i'll throw it
out there with the help
joe thomas right here on the rich
housing show how are you joe i'm doing
great thanks for having me on rich so uh
you're a man well versed in uh seeing uh
backup quarterbacks or quarterbacks not
uh the starter in cleveland ohio uh that
was another situation i guess it was
fitting that you were there last night
you know yeah i feel like baker probably
would have played had he known i
wasn't going to be there but since every
time i come to cleveland there's a new
quarterback that's under center it just
felt right that case was going to be the
one that was taking the snaps and
playing some good football some winning
football for this bronze team that
desperately needed that win last night
now i was calling my shot earlier this
week i was feeling my my oats man and i
was saying like i'm like look case
when he does well
when he performs well because he is
good in this role this role of needing
to come off the bench and being there
and giving you the football that you
need to win and also he knows the system
the coach knows him that's why he's
there right like this is essentially why
he's there he is an outstanding backup
to um baker mayfield and i do not say
that in any way shape or form other than
being complimentary although case might
not feel that way but i basically set
this all up to say is that there there's
no sense there in cleveland that that
this is
case's job
is there
no
not not not right now i mean that might
be something that could be talked about
later on but i think
right now browns fans are just very
excited about what they saw last night
because it was a season that was really
on the brink at three and three to go to
three and four and lose to the broncos
on national television the mindset in
cleveland and in the building for the
browns would have been completely
different uh it would have been so much
more dour and it would have been tough
to talk themselves into how do we save
the season right but having case go out
there and play as efficiently as he did
i mean he was tremendous with the play
action pass and to see the running game
thrive without nick chubb and kareem
hunt
and to see a guy that is very much
beloved in cleveland in the building and
dearness johnson have a breakout game in
his first game as a start in the nfl was
really the type of story line that you
needed to feel great about where you
were going especially as the browns head
into one of the most difficult schedules
in the nfl coming up yeah i mean
dearness johnson coming up with a big
game and and again keenum you know um
i guess let's put a pin in that part of
the conversation i should have led with
this with you
him on the set with you and colleen and
you know irv and steve last night was
just um
great when he said you just you know you
don't have to what do you say you don't
have to get ready you don't have to get
ready when you are staying ready yeah
right and then and then you're like
that's it what a walk off and he just
you know said i'm out see it like
constantly it was beautiful yeah it was
beautiful it was the best mic drop in
cleveland since mgk did it at the draft
when we were there uh in the spring and
it was it was just such a great moment
because i think like you mentioned
earlier off the top like kevin stefanski
as the head coach having case keenum
here understanding the offense
understanding how to operate efficiently
getting the ball where it needs to go
and not really losing a beat from having
baker and they're giving your playmakers
an opportunity to make plays and then
having an offensive line that's been
banged up a tackle getting jed wheels
back getting that running game going i
think it really kind of paves a
blueprint to win some of these games
especially as you're beat beat up a
little bit for them to kind of feel
really good as they get guys healthy in
the next couple weeks yeah i mean it
helps to have the mini buy here and then
on the end of the mini buy or two
crucial
highly important division games their
first of the year with the steelers and
the bengals right after
this mini buy so
do you think
that they can get wins in those games
with case keenum joe thomas what do you
think as long as they're able to run the
ball the way they have been and the way
they did last night i i believe that
case keenum has absolutely the tools
necessary to win all the games in the
division i'm not saying they're going to
go 6-0 here but
i think i feel that as long as they can
run the ball what case keenum does
really well is he is really good in the
play action i think he was like 10 of 13
last night with 130 some rating um in
play action and and that can only happen
if you're effective running the ball so
with that offensive line bill callahan
uh setting up the run game for those
guys it really is something that can
open up that whole offense and case
keenum is the efficient quarterback that
they need to be able to
run that and win some of those big games
especially if they've got a defense that
is going to continue to improve what do
you think is going through baker
mayfield's mind this morning joe
he's extremely happy that they won but
he's also extremely excited to hopefully
get out there as soon as possible
because this is his team and it always
has been um and it's killing him not be
able to be out there he's such a
competitor
but also as as a quarterback or as as a
any player in the nfl when you're seeing
your backup go in there and play well
you're saying hey
that's great i'm happy but i want to be
the one that's out there making the
plays because i certainly don't want to
have any sort of quarterback controversy
here once i do get ready to be healthy
and get back out there why would there
be a quarterback controversy i mean and
that's that's that was what i've been
talking about for the last
couple of weeks you know i mean part of
the reason why that game was won last
night is because the defense did stand
up and take care of business against an
offensive unit that that was um you know
ready there to be beaten you know what i
mean and it's this team game it always
seems to be falling on baker's
shoulders whether they're healthy or not
so
why would there be one i don't that that
one is kind of mystifying to me joe you
want to translate it
that's a great question baker has always
been one of the most polarizing figures
in sports certainly in the nfl people
love him people hate him and i think
when you have that type of personality
and you're in the spotlight as much as
he is and you know he's never shied away
from uh picking some fights in the media
or with other players um i think when
when you have that big personality
you're to have people that are going to
want to shoot you down they're going to
want to give every opportunity when they
see an opening to knock you down a peg
right wrong or indifferent and
baker's been up and down this season he
has i mean
i think in brown's nation the
expectations are to win a super bowl and
they want to see their quarterback
consistently play super bowl winning
football and baker has done that at
times but he just hasn't been i think
consistent enough not saying that case
keemum gives them a better opportunity
to win a super bowl because i don't
think he does um but i think you add all
those factors together and that's why
baker is such a great and fun topic for
people in the national media and even a
lot of people in cleveland and in the
browns nation uh they love to talk about
baker well joe thomas i know that browns
fans would love to say you know
let's win they're going to hoist the
super bowl this year trophy up the road
from the studio in los angeles and
they'll remember i guess that thursday
night win
to spark it all with case keenum when
they were all banged up and then baker
came back and everyone got healthy and
then they started dominating it's just
tough to see that point be from this
current point a to be very honest with
you when there's the ravens atop their
division uh the bills despite their loss
to tennessee derrick henry running wild
the way that he is and then of course
whoever might come out of the afc west
so
how do you handicap the afc as we're
currently getting set for the rest of
week seven joe yeah you you really make
it sound tough because in my head the
browns had already won the super bowl
sorry
sorry no i i i agree i think the browns
certainly in all aspects need to play
better if they want to have serious
super bowl aspirations because you
mentioned how difficult the afc is
already at baseline with the buffalo
bills and the kansas city chiefs and the
las vegas raiders and then you look over
at the afc north and that might be the
best division in football all of a
sudden after some early struggles by the
steelers and not really understanding
how good the bengals are now the bengals
all of a sudden have this really good
defense they've got this young
quarterback joe burrow who's playing
outstanding football and then lamar
jackson in the mvp race again and then
all of a sudden the pittsburgh steelers
start to figure things out a little bit
and you've got a division that you know
i don't know what it looks like at the
end of the season but you might have
three four teams that are over 500 that
are all vying for that last playoff spot
in the afc down to week 18 so it's
certainly going to be a challenge for
the browns
but i like where they're they're
sitting right now because i think
defensively if they can continue to play
a little bit better and they just keep
leaning on that run game getting chubb
and hunt back
it's a tough
formula for other teams to handle
when you're playing in december when
you're playing in the afc north run the
ball
play stout on defense get after the
quarterback with a pass rush i like that
formula for winning down the stretch who
was your preseason pick for winning the
super bowl joe thomas i'm sure it was
the browns i i have no idea remember
various shows that i was on
what i picked but certainly i i'm a
homer for the browns no i know that but
i'm just trying to i'm trying to say i
have the uh the chiefs taking on
the bucks again i just decided like it's
been a long time since we've gotten uh a
return engagement um kind of like where
the bucks are playing and how they're
sitting right there what do you think of
the chiefs are you thinking that they're
vulnerable or that
we're it's still too early
i think they're vulnerable especially
when you look at just the resurgence of
all these other great teams looking at
arizona how great tampa bay is playing
green bay is rolling you've got the
ravens and the bills and the afc and
tennessee's coming on and you know
there's just
so much quality talent from top to
bottom that have great offenses and
defenses that i just don't think the way
kansas city is built with so much
pressure on this offense to score so
prolifically that they're going to be
able to make a run through the playoffs
and win a super bowl because it's just
so difficult to be at your best
for an offense every single week
to be able to make your way through and
to not have a defense to be able to lean
on at all
so i i think
you look at the bills in the afc and
right now the way the ravens are playing
they're just a much more well-rounded
football team that's built to be able to
go in and maybe one side has a bad game
but the other side can pick it up and
kansas city doesn't have that right now
and who's your favorite in the nfc what
do you like you got to choose one that's
the way we do it on sports right now i'm
picking the cardinals i love where that
team is the defense
is sort of a little bit like the bengals
when i think about them right the
bengals had this defense that nobody was
really talking about but it was really
really a big part of where they are
right now and last year the cardinals
their defense is what had them in a lot
of those games and then this year
defense plan even better with the
addition of jj watt and now they've got
an offense with weapons that we haven't
seen since maybe the greatest show on
turf just torching people on that side
of the football it's just a really
difficult
team to defend especially on offense
because they're beating you with
athletes i mean how do you practice for
guys that are just more athletic than
your dudes in one-on-one situations the
way they spread you out it's difficult
to come up with a scheme to make your
guys better athletes yeah i know we were
we were we were talking the other day
with marshall faulk saying it's
impossible
to scout team against derrick henry
because what are you going to use a
defensive end
you know and that that's what marshall
said earlier this week so you got to use
a defensive end to the scout team for
derek henry i wouldn't know how how do
you scout team for
for kyler murray right i mean like
that's yeah that's a that's a tough comp
for your on your 50 feet i agree you
know you look at the playoffs when do
teams usually get
their toes stubbed in the playoffs
that's right somebody's been coming been
game planning and they come up with this
really good game plan to kind of take
away what your go-to plays are you know
we saw it in the super bowl with the
rams a few years ago against the
patriots right you know bill belichick
comes up with this great game plan and
this scheme to be able to shut down
schematically what that offense does
really well but when what you do really
well like arizona is we just spread you
out and play basketball and then we just
out athlete you at every position like
how do you come up with a game plan to
defend that you can't there is no game
plan that can make your dudes better in
a one-on-one situation because even when
you have the perfect defense called like
we've seen multiple times this year and
you got kyler murray on the edge running
to his left and you got guys that are
ready to make the play he makes a little
shimmy and a shake and all of a sudden
your dude's on the ground and he's
running for a 15-yard first down as a
defensive coordinator you're just
ripping your hair out because you worked
so hard to put your guys in position to
win a one-on-one battle that typically
is in their favor against the
quarterback and then you lose that's
just got to be so discouraging for a
defense
joe thomas appreciate the time always
love watching you on tnf on nfl network
and so much more let's do this again
very shortly we'll uh look for my call
thanks for thanks for the time joe
thanks rich i appreciate you having me
on you got it six-time all-pro 10-time
pro bowler at joe thomas 73 on twitter
joe thomas on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here